ROSS KUKULINSKI:
Thank you, Chris.
So again, my name
is Ross Kukulinski.
I'm working with a newly
formed group called SpeakIt.io.
We're actually a
spinoff out of a company
that's been doing real-time
sound and communication
systems for flight simulators
and military training
and gaming applications.
So we're sort of
coming at WebRTC
from a slightly different angle.
We're not
telecommunication people.
We're not web developers.
I mean, we are, but we're coming
at a very different angle.
And basically the
previous presentation
was a perfect
warm-up, because we're
going to go more in-depth
into how you can potentially
scale your WebRTC applications
from beyond 10 to 20 people
in a conference to 200 or 2,000.
So far today, we've heard
WebRTC is fundamentally
a peer-to-peer application.
Peer-to-peer is awesome.
It gets back to the
decentralized nature
of the internet.
It takes control and puts it
back into us as web developers.
It puts the control
back into the endpoints.
And that's awesome, until
you need to get big.
So before we get
into that, I want
to cover a couple of
audio vocabulary terms
that I'm going to
throw out there.
Most web developers
maybe won't necessarily
need to deal with
this, but if you're
going to build a
scalable application,
these words are
going to come up.
So first of all, transcoding.
So the idea of transcoding,
if you have an audio stream,
it's going to have
a certain codec.
It might be Opus.
It might be VP8.
It might have a signal rate.
Transcoding is the
transfer of that data
from one interpretation
to another.
And the reason you need
to do that is in order
to mix two audio
streams, they need
to be in fundamentally
the same format.
So in terms of
audio scalability,
we end up mixing audio.
Now, Chrome and Firefox
or browser limitations
that's underneath in the
WebRTC implementation,
they are doing this for you.
But if you're going to build
a scalable architecture,
you probably need some other
larger system to handle that.
The other item
that I may mention
is Acoustic Echo
Cancellation, or AEC.
Chrome and Firefox have them
built in to some degree.
They're now in the getUserMedia.
When we first started building
this, none of that was there.
So we've actually
built our own version.
And we're doing some
parallel testing
of doing AEC in the
browser in our own code
in addition to comparing
it against the reference
implementation specs.
So this is a fully
meshed architecture.
When we are seeing
these demonstrations,
this is usually what's
happening in terms of the media
stream that's going
between the nodes.
We've got three nodes
here-- A, B, and C.
And each one is sending
its own media stream
to the other peers.
If you only have three people,
this is pretty straightforward.
Chrome browser and Firefox are
really, really good at this.
This is six nodes.
It's still going to
work just fine in most
of the current browsers today.
But if you make this 60 nodes,
all of those interconnection
things means increased bandwidth
and increased CPU usage
at each of those nodes.
The kind folks at
Google and Mozilla,
they're working
really, really hard
to get their
browsers to be better
at handling large
number of connections.
But at some point,
the browsers aren't
going to be able to keep
up, especially if you're
doing applications like gaming.
The browser is
going to be focused
on doing the video rendering and
other actions on the platform,
and so audio is
going to get dropped
towards the bottom of the
implementation details.
So what are some ways
we can get around this?
One, we could change
our architecture
and go to a star mesh, where
we are able to locate-- maybe
we've got a node somewhere.
Someone's desktop computer has
got massive processing power,
and we can take
advantage of that.
So maybe B and C and E and D
are clients that-- maybe they're
mobile clients.
Or maybe they are
less powerful laptops.
They can offload some of that
mixing and transcoding work
to A.
We'll make this bigger.
We actually could
even do something
where we've got multiple stars.
And some of the early versions
of the Skype platform, this
is actually what they used for
their signaling and always-on
peer-to-peer network.
Here we could use this and do
this with the data platform.
One of the problems
with this, though,
is that it's hard to determine,
at least with current APIs
available in the
browser, which platforms
are going to be powerful
enough to do this.
It hits at that noisy neighbor.
What other things are
running on that browser
or running on that box?
How do you know which ones
are going to the best nodes
to do that processing?
So the other alternative,
which we've been hearing,
is this thing of MCU,
Multipoint Control Unit.
These are actually new words
to my group over the last six
months, because we're not coming
from the telecommunications.
But it's a more traditional
client server architecture,
where A, B, and C
are generic nodes.
So they might be a mobile
browser or a web browser.
They might be a native
app running on a device.
Here, the MCU is going to do
all of the transcoding, all
of the mixing of that
audio, potentially video.
There's a number of
different MCU options
that you can choose as
an application developer.
There are open source
ones that you can take.
A lot of them work pretty well.
They're self-contained.
There's a couple of providers
that are providing that as
one-off, like you rent a server.
And then there's a couple
of platform-as-a-service
providers.
I'm not going to do
any naming names.
But this is what
it looks like when
you get to a larger conference.
Here we're back to
our six clients.
And you'll notice
that A through F,
even though there's
six nodes now,
they still only have
one stream going out
and one stream coming in.
The MCU is taking care
of all of the processing
and transcoding, with
the exception of the one
transcoding for node A
to go from whatever's
on the network stream
to translating out
the audio device.
And that's going to
be in the browser.
And you're going to have
to do that no matter what.
But the idea is to offload
some of that extra work.
So what are the advantages
of having an MCU
as part of your
WebRTC application?
Well, number one, it offloads
processing from your endpoints.
It also allows you to
do more things with it.
You can do things like
recording or transcription.
Maybe you have a
conference or game,
you can store that
data for later,
do live, real-time
speech recognition,
and translate that data.
You also can rebroadcast that.
So if you have a participant
list, if you're building,
let's say, a podcast platform.
And you've got one
or two co-hosts,
and maybe they've got
four or five people
they're going to call in.
But maybe you've got
10,000 subscribers
that want to listen
to this podcast live.
Taking advantage
of an MCU allows
you to rebroadcast that out.
And then finally, you
can do cool things
like having sound effects
and text to speech and music
to keep yourselves occupied.
All right.
So I'm going to
talk a little bit
about how we've built
out our application.
So let's start at
the very bottom here.
So we have our browser objects.
So the little B squares
at the bottom, those
are your browsers.
So they might be
a desktop browser.
They may be a mobile device.
And the first version
of this we built
was before there was the
echo canceling in the Chrome
platform.
And we were building
this for our own use,
for our own company.
We are a distributed company.
We have employees
scattered all over.
So we wanted an easy way
for us to all communicate.
So we actually said to heck
with the peer connection stuff.
Let's use getUserMedia.
Let's get the microphone,
attach the speaker.
Let's send that data over a
WebSocket back to our server,
and then back to our
MCU in the back end.
One of the first things
that we ran into in terms
of performance
problem was the fact
that Node.js, which was
the platform we're using,
doesn't handle SSL termination.
SSL is the secure link between
your browser and the server.
And so in order to offload
that work from Node.js,
we put an EngineX set of
load balancers in between.
That allows SSL
connection to be moved,
and then Node.js
is able to handle
all of the websocket
connections.
Then from Node.js,
we're able to pipe
that data back to our MCUs,
which then can mix the audio,
transcode it, get
everything all set up,
and then ship it
all the way back.
On the right-hand
side of the image,
we have the control interface.
So not unlike
Squiggle, we've built
a REST API to handle
the setting up
and tearing down of
rooms, which in our case
in a local mixing
cluster, we're using Redis
as our pub/sub messaging
system between our Node.js
clusters and our MCUs, and
then our node REST API.
However, once the peer
connection in Chrome
got their echo canceling
on board, we started work--
and we're still in the process
of finishing up this platform.
Basically, we've
removed the need
for having that EngineX
web server in the way.
So now we can have
direct connection
from the browser to a peer
connection running in Node.js.
There's actually
a C plug-in that's
running underneath Node that's
handling the raw binaries data.
And then we're able to transmit
and send that back to our MCUs.
And then, on the
right-hand side,
I simplified things
and just put config.
It's actually the same
configuration we have here,
but I got sick of drawing.
OK, so as you're building
out this MCU platform,
one of the cool things
is that now you've
got this back-end service.
Now, for web developers or the
architecture side of people,
this is where things, in my
opinion, get real exciting.
Now you can take all
of those audio streams
and send them off
to something else
and do really cool
things with them.
So you can do things
like recording,
doing speech recognition,
text to speech,
feeding data back in, being able
to recognize when a user gives
a command.
So we could have Google
Glass sitting back there.
You can give commands to
your media control system
and have it do stuff, tie
into your HipChat system
or whatever it may be.
A lot of the open source MCUs
are self-contained boxes.
They're not able to communicate
with other platforms.
Not all of them, but that
tends to be a common thing.
So there's a decision you have
to make as an implementer.
Do we want a given
room, when it's
built-- is the room going to
be self-contained entirely
in one of those MCUs?
In other words, all
the browsers may
go through one of the different
Node.js hops and eventually may
make their way all to one MCU.
And that MCU is going to
contain some number of rooms,
but each room is going to
be entirely in that MCU.
There's some advantages to that.
One advantage is that
in terms of simplicity,
that MCU can be
highly optimized.
It just has to mix the
audio right there in memory
and then ship it back
out over the network.
It also, in my
opinion, has a feature
in that if you do have something
that's going to go down
and if your MCU does have a
crash or something happens--
which, things happen--
then the entire room goes
down all at once.
The alternative is,
if you have your room
spread across multiple MCUs,
if one of them goes down,
you might get in this
half-on, half-off state, where
some of your clients view
the room as being live
and everyone's
there and connected,
but maybe half the people
aren't hearing anything.
That's an architectural
decision that you'll
need to make and find out what
that trade-off is for you.
We've elected to, for
now, keep everything
all self-contained
in a single MCU.
And this is how, if we
were to do this, which
our platform does support,
we're siding with trying
to keep things all
self-contained.
But it could be done through
multicast networking.
You also could, in
theory, take advantage
of WebRTC between
your MCUs and have
them sync in a peer-to-peer
fashion as well.
Obviously, if you're going to
get to a large enough scale,
you don't want to have
everything just in one data
center.
You want to have
multiple data centers.
And the pub/sub that we have
here is actually-- we're
also using RabbitMQ that
the Squiggle folks are using
for the AMQP data transfer, the
consistent state of what rooms
do we have across the
entire infrastructure?
Not just one data center or
not just one mixing cluster,
but what is the entire state
of the entire application?
And the reason that we're taking
advantage of pub/sub suggesting
is A, it's low latency.
We can send lots and lots
of messages between our data
centers.
If we need to, we
can store them,
if there's too much traffic.
We also can scale up
our RabbitMQ system.
If we just had a
single database,
then we're tied to
a single database.
So that's cool.
At least, I think so.
So now what?
So you're building
an application.
You're a developer.
You're trying to figure
out what to build.
What decisions do
you need to make?
Well, first of all, you need
to analyze your requirements.
Are you just
building an app where
you need-- let's say it's
a medical application.
You have a doctor who needs
to interact with a patient.
You probably don't
need all of this.
Traditional STUN
and TURN server is
going to provide the
capability to get
those browsers connected.
Chrome and Firefox and
Opera and hopefully
eventually Internet
Explorer and Safari
will pick up these new features.
The next question is,
if you do need an MCU,
are you going to be
Squiggle and roll your own,
go through the fun process of
building out your own system?
Or are you going to go with
a commercial application?
There are companies that sell
just a standalone MCU, where
you can just take
that and drop it in.
That may work if you
know that you only
need somewhere between 100
or 200, 500 people in a room.
That may work just fine.
However, you probably
will have to figure out
how to group them
together and deal
with the scalability
and that sort of thing.
Open source, off the
shelf, or hosted?
All of which really, really
fundamentally depend on what
are your specific requirements.
That's all I have.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
Thank you, Ross.
We're actually running, believe
it or not, ahead of schedule.
But don't get too
excited, because we're
going to-- yeah,
[? Serge is ?] coming.
It's coming.
Do we have any
questions for Ross?
Yes, please speak up.
Ross, come back up.
And be sure to
repeat the question.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I must
have spaced it out,
but in one of your slides, you
went from browser to Node.js.
ROSS KUKULINSKI: Yes.
AUDIENCE: How did you accomplish
your SSL requirements?
ROSS KUKULINSKI:
There is a module.
I'm now blanking on
the name of the module.
What they've done is
they've taken a node module,
and they have native
libraries underneath that
are wrapped as a Node.js module.
And the underlying
code is loaded
into the V8 runtime,
which then does
all of the SSL and the security.
So Node is then dealing
with the security,
so we actually are having to
increase the number of Node.js
servers that we
have to handle that.
Because before, we had EngineX,
which is really, really
good at handling
SSL termination.
AUDIENCE: And you gave
up load balancing also?
MALE SPEAKER: Repeat
the question, please.
ROSS KUKULINSKI: Oh, sorry.
The question is, in
addition to switching away
with the EngineX, we also
gave up the load balancing.
The load balancing is actually
part of the configuration.
You're right.
I missed this is my drawing.
As part of our library that
we've built into the browser
SDK, it's able to communicate
with the config on the far
right and figure out
which data center
or which Node.js pure
connection termination to make.
So basically the browser
initiates a pure connection
as part of the
STUN configuration.
It's told which room to join.
And then one of
the Node.js nodes
will then join that appropriate.
So then we have a
one-to-one connection
between the browser and Node.js.
AUDIENCE: Do you know the
framework for the node SSL
that you used?
ROSS KUKULINSKI: I do not
know the name of the node SSL
library off the top of my head.
I'd be happy to talk
with you afterwards.
Yeah, there's a question
in the way back.
AUDIENCE: You said that you
were sending the audio raw?
Does that mean
without any coding?
ROSS KUKULINSKI: I
believe the question--
and correct me if
I'm wrong-- is are we
sending the audio raw
without any encoding?
In this implementation,
where we're
talking through WebSocket, we
are sending 16-bit PCM audio.
So it works extremely well on
higher bandwidth applications.
Obviously, we've been testing
on Chrome Android devices.
On a decent Wi-Fi
network, it works fine.
As you start to get
to 4G modems, it's OK.
Usually it starts to fall over.
And our current implementation
does not work at all on 3G.
When we built this,
our primary target
was for ourselves as developers
to be able to communicate.
And we're all at the office
or at the different offices
or at home with very solid
internet connections.
With this new platform, we
take advantage of everything
that Chrome browser does
underneath the hood,
in terms of the Opus codecs
and VP8 and all that stuff.
Another question in the back.
AUDIENCE: Is the MCU a browser?
ROSS KUKULINSKI: Is
the MCU a browser?
AUDIENCE: Hardware or software?
ROSS KUKULINSKI:
Oh, it's a software.
Ours is entirely a Linux-based
real-time audio platform.
It's what we've built for flight
simulation, military training.
We have these installations
with thousands of flight sims
and soldiers running
around playing video games,
and we provide the real-time
voice communication
for all that.
So for us, our MCU is a
software-based Linux real-time
platform.
A lot of the other MCUs--
like there's Jitsi.
It's got the video bridge.
There's a couple of others
that are Java-based.
And there are also
hardware-based MCUs.
But our issue with
hardware-based MCUs
is then you need lots
and lots of hardware.
And then we can't take
advantage of cloud providers
like Rackspace or DigitalOcean
or AWS in terms of scalability.
And I've been told
that's the last question.
So if there are any
other questions,
we've got the break next.
So I'll stick around up here.
If you want to ask me
questions, I'm here.
Thanks.
MALE SPEAKER: Thanks, Ross.
Ross has got a
wealth of knowledge.
Please tap into him.